remember the house Foreign Relations
Committee Iraq war vet himself Congress
and kids ago thanks for being here so
this three bit listen yes dan is wrong
the Crypt is actually pretty creepy may
be undersold it you might have undersold
it so yeah what do you make of this bill
I mean we've been talking about all
morning all the items in it Nancy Pelosi
strong-arming her caucus to get it
passed what's your take so look all this
is is you know it's disappointing
because we've done four or five
coronavirus related bills that we're all
bipartisan you know we can go debate
them and all that kind of stuff but it'd
be when it's all done we do a bipartisan
thing this is not that this is November
focused so what she wants to do for
instance there was a repeal of the state
and local income tax deduction that
gives her blue state vulnerable
Democrats the opportunity to say that
they voted for that you know that
affects you and then by the way your
opponent probably wouldn't have and and
so what you've done is you've taken a
bill that she knows is going nowhere and
she's made it a political weapon for
November we need to resist you know
following suit of using this pandemic as
political weapons and we're doing that
for the most part but they can't help
themselves and and that's what that was
it was a disappointing not real attempt
to govern and help the American people
that need it really badly
you know congressman her assumption
though is that people will do no
research people will just assume Oh
Republicans must not care about you know
people suffering with kovat but instead
people are actually looking at this and
they're they're aware of what she's done
which is to try to paint something as
this is for coronavirus relief when in
fact she has stuffed it with all this
entire left-wing agenda so are people
like Nancy Pelosi just convinced that
the American people are dumb you know
like maybe I just think what it is is
she gets pulled so far to the left I
mean she actually looks moderate in
comparison to some of these new
Democrats she gets pulled so far to the
left she has to appease them and you
know unlike the old days when you know
we actually didn't have a 30 trillion
dollar debt almost she thinks that she
can just author this kind of Christmas
tree of whatever anybody wants and and I
saw her in an interview where she was
kind of giggling about how big this was
gonna be and you know we're gonna
some real tough decisions to make when
the economy recovers because of our debt
and it's just not a serious attempt to
govern like this is a real moment this
is something that should be bringing us
together with serious conversations and
it had legislatively up until yesterday
it's disappointing but you know what the
adults here will come in we'll take over
in the Senate yeah and we'll get
something done ultimately and
Congressman you adults also do oversight
I want to ask you about President Trump
Fox News is reporting the President
Trump is possibly going to restore
partial funding to the World Health
Organization after pause to investigate
the corona virus response obviously by
now most Americans are aware that China
suppress and try to conceal the outbreak
here is the tweet we're getting from
President Trump responding to one of our
hosts Lou Dobbs says Lou this is just
one of numerous concepts being
considered under which we would pay 10
percent of what we have been paying over
many years matching much lower China
payments have not made final decision
all funds are frozen
thanks but congressman as we know the
w-h-o was tweeting that the human human
transmission wasn't a factor early on
cost thousands if not millions of cases
to break out yes so I think it's
actually an interesting concept because
the issue with the w-h-o we don't want
to just abandon it and disband it but we
want the head of the w-h-o gone he is
absolutely in the pocket of China and
there's no better opportunity than to
say we're gonna withdraw most of our
funding we'll still have a seat at the
table but if you want US money you're
gonna have to make a change and we've
seen these Intel agencies around the
world and in Europe particularly saying
yeah in fact we know that the head of
w-h-o had a conversation with China and
then you know cast his vote against
declaring this a pandemic called it the
most transparent you know country in the
world basically on this so we need
answers I think the answer here is not
to diss pay on the w-h-o it's to have
real changes and take out Chinese
influence in it and I think if the
president makes this decision it may be
an interesting opportunity to use that
money as leverage for change
congressman I want to shift over to some
of the protests that are going on
particularly in Illinois with the states
stay at home order that's in place until
the end of the month so what are
constituents saying to you about this
well they're pretty ticked off so in
Peru Illinois a Hobby Lobby somebody you
know called and tattle-tale that it was
open so the police had to come and shut
it down they didn't storm it but you
know they showed up and said hey we're
under orders to shut this down
Hobby Lobby shut down Hobby Lobby right
I think what's happening is you have
people might my districts mostly rules
sometimes are like a hundred people
that's already socially distanced and
but they're being treated as if they're
in a hot spot like Chicago and the
governor when he comes out and he
threatens things like I'm gonna withhold
federal funding from these local
communities that makes people even
angrier and I think what these kind of
left-wing governors are forgetting is
that people are free in America and
they'll be voluntarily you know to help
to stop a pandemic but they don't want
to have your thumb put on them
particularly after we have flattened the
curve and we were told what do you think
do you think people should start opening
up sort of responsible civil
disobedience saying you can't shut us
down forever my business will go under
so I'm not gonna call for that I'm gonna
say you know that I think that the state
of Illinois and the governor needs to
make even more flexibility to his plan
make it achievable and understand that
you know if people wear masks in public
and keep their distance we can basically
prevent the spread as much as a lockdown
can - we shall see Adam Kinzinger thank
you very much appreciate your time this
morning
anytime you guys